CBS News legal analyst Jonathan Turley
is with us he testified at bars
confirmation hearing in January and has
known him for years
Jonathan good morning thank you let's
address this central question why would
the Attorney General of the United
States hold a press conference before
either lawmakers or the press or the
public has seen the report well I think
for Bill bars perspective he views this
as trying to explain the process he's
taken a lot of hits over the last couple
weeks about the redaction process and I
think he understands that the product is
only going to be as as relied upon or or
viewed favorably as you do the process
itself and I think he's gonna try to
explain that but look there's going to
be so much spin in the city it's going
to take the earth off its rotational
access axis I mean I think it is it is
par for the course today that people are
going to read into this let's try and
ignore the circus yeah focus on the
substance right the first thing you're
gonna be looking for is what it says
about obstruction right right
you know it's a 400-page report it has
it's gonna be the stylistic rage of a
color-coded report for legal analysts
which frankly is quite helpful but I'm
gonna turn to the second half on
obstruction and specifically I'm going
to be looking for anything referencing
Don began the White House Council gave
three interviews for over 30 hours that
is an eternity for a sitting White House
Counsel he was also president many of
the critical moments but some news
reports suggest that he may have stopped
the president from firing critical
players that does go to obstruction so
the obstruction section of this report
is likely to have the meat of what we're
looking for as opposed to collusion and
we'll also have answers from the
president presumably as a part of the
investigation Jonathan give us your
standard here for how to evaluate this
material because there's the question of
whether you can indict a president or
prosecute them outside of the political
process and then there's impeachment so
how should we measure what we're reading
in this report well we're going to be
looking for different types of
information right obviously the most
obvious is you look for indictable
conduct the Department of Justice has
indicated that it doesn't see that
conduct we'll be looking for impeachable
conduct because obviously Congress can
act on if evidence it might fall short
of a crime and still impeach someone and
then I expect you're going to find a lot
of contemptible conduct conduct that is
not criminal
but may shocked the conscience which are
not likely to find is a lot of
commendable conduct right this is the
type of report that's likely to be quite
damaging to the president you know the
Democrats are calling for him mr. Barr
to not have this news conference you
know him does it make sense to you there
their concern is that he's going to
paint a narrative that's very favorable
to the president before anybody gets to
see the report you know him do you think
this is how he operates
I don't I think that bill Barr is
viewing this as a way of laying out for
people this is the what you're going to
get this is the report this is how it
was produced these are the people who
redacted
he didn't redact this report he had a
team of people know he had a team of
people and rod Rosenstein the Deputy
Attorney General was involved robert
muller was involved and he's going to
lay out how these things were done so
the so the american people understand
what they're about to see and how it
came about
is it even realistic to see it with no
redactions no there's no when people say
they want the full-on redacted report
that is not going to happen
rule six the information or grand jury
information cannot be released publicly
and just last week the DC Circuit made
it an even tougher standard for judges
to release this information all right
Jonathan Turley thank you we want to let
everybody know that when the Attorney
General holds his news conference CBS
News will bring it to you in a special
report now it is scheduled to begin at
9:30 a.m. Eastern Time 8:30 central and
we will be back with more on that